if you're looking for ways to get
word-of-mouth form collaborations and
have an iron skin then this video is for
you you know you want to be a youtuber
and an influencer just know the hey is
coming and when I first started I mean
even now still collaborations are huge
they hope they help you grow
word-of-mouth word-of-mouth best
marketing of a best marketing everything
that's crazy is until about six months
ago I didn't realize that because I'm a
social media guy need motivation
watching top 10 with the leave nation
what's up it's having my wine or
disbelieve and I believe in you I
believe in that amazing thing you have
inside you that I want to see burst out
into the world so let's get your
motivation to attend and have you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
on today's lessons from a man who went
from dropping out of college to pursue
social media as a career full-time to
then becoming one of the most popular
youtubers of all time with billions of
views on his channel he's logan paul and
here's my take on his top ten rules of
success enjoy
all right let's take things off with
rule number one create good content when
you said you try to make videos go viral
what I mean that's every marketing
agency as if we want to make a viral
video right it's mostly oh yeah yeah
yeah what is like what's the secret
sauce is it um SEL yeah that is that is
the question it is not SEO I I really
believe that good content is good
content and if it's worthy of going
viral like it will right and I've just
gotten really I have a good track record
a win much more than I win much more
than I lose mm-hmm so I kind of know the
system and I think the best way to put
it is that the Internet is a language
there's a language the Millennials speak
it I speak in I understand the language
i speaker really well so I can make
content it's sort of just it's it's I
know it like the back of my hand I know
what's gonna work and I know what's not
gonna work
sure and like I said after doing it for
so long it becomes very clear that hate
this video has a very good chance of
going viral I could I'm wrong sometimes
right right more than what's considered
a win like what's the threshold of
viewership where you're like this didn't
flop uh I don't really have flops
anymore like the best answer like like I
said I've gotten good at tailoring the
contest there is no bad content and if
if it's not good cuz I have a brain
trust of people I can shoot a video edit
it what does that team look like around
you my friends my demographic you know
King batch Amanda Cerny my roommate
other creators yeah exactly
hey do you think this is funny nah man I
don't like my feelings kind of hurt but
in the end it's better for my career
right right so I know when I put out a
video it's gonna be it's gonna be
minimum you're gonna ago I was good
again it's all about like when people
see that name Logan Paul I want them to
think a certain way I want that I don't
want it to be like oh he just he pushes
videos out every day that are kind of
subpar when I put a video out I want it
to be a banger so I'm a huge fan of this
rule and and what I add to it is I think
the quantity leads to the quality the
more you do it the more you
do it the more you do it the better the
quality gets every single time these top
tens we're trying to prove the quality
every single time we've done hundreds of
them and trying to improve it every
single time and so expect your first
video if you're making content to suck
and that's okay and the next one has to
be better and you just continually try
to improve it until you're consistently
making good content let's go to rule
number two have iron skin so what advice
you give to someone who's eight years
old who wants to put content up and of
all the haters that may comment and just
like destroy his fear it's horrible it's
horrible but my mom goes I want to do
vlogs my mom vlogs guys she's got like
700,000 subscribers this is my mother
she's 55 when she goes I want to do
vlogs I'm like mom you have no idea the
Internet is gonna tear you apart no I'm
fine week later calls me sobbing look at
you all of these people are saying about
me my wrinkles really that bad am I not
funny I'm like mom I told you you gotta
have iron skin but as an eight-year-old
it's hard to have iron skin because
you're eight so I'd say I'd say if you
gotta if you know you want to be a
youtuber and an influencer just know the
hay is coming the negative comments are
good when I had acne in college when I
was doing vines and like I get comments
like you look like a burn victim
whatever I like oh like they hurt me but
at the end of the day you do cares
there's like five of them saying that
another great clip for anybody who's
creating content or has a message that
they want to send out there to the world
I think the thing that really helped me
with developing more of an iron skin I
don't know that it ever really goes away
I think there's still some things that
get through and still hurt but just they
don't hurt for as long and you get used
to it I think just the environment
really helped by me surrounded myself
with with visionary Steve Jobs etc
people who get constantly picked on and
criticized and attacked and seeing how
they deal with it having that that
resilience in your environment makes you
more resilient
and then also having it happen more
frequently you know we're fortunate here
believe nation is super friendly for the
most part we still get some haters
everybody will get some dislikes you get
used to it more and more you get used to
it and so you develop your skin over
time that it's not just your sock and an
instant thick skin right or instant iron
skin it comes with time and experience
let's keep it moving rule number three
be competitive tell me about how you
started on vine like how it all happened
yes so so the here's the funny story
that I tell everyone my brother had four
hundred followers and I had two hundred
okay and we were making a vine and I
suggested my brother I'm like yo Jake
why don't you do this why don't you try
this and he turns me he's like oh yeah
Logan who has more followers like I know
what I'm doing and I was like it's gonna
be like that holla Jake so like that's
when the brotherly competition started
next day I'm out there like producing
vines that took effort you know not just
like a typical mom dad dog like vines
stuff that could appeal to a lot of
people and so I started doing that and
next thing you know in about like a week
and a half
I got refined by one of the bigger
Viners 2,000 followers 5,000 followers
next thing you know what I'm a hundred
thousand I look one day and I'm at a
million and it's nuts and my brother now
actually has four hundred thousand - but
you're winning Yeah right I won the the
brother competition that yeah I think
competition can really make you stronger
it shouldn't be the only reason why
you're doing something it's not the
reason to be an entrepreneur just to
beat somebody but having some friendly
competition can push you to drive a
little bit further just like if you're
running a race against three-year-olds
or eight-year-olds like you're gonna win
every time so you're not really focused
on putting your best effort each time
but having somebody who's at your heels
all the time we might be ahead of you
pushes you to push that little bit extra
juice add that may not have been there
before for me and starting youtube at
the beginning that was Grant Cardone he
was that the same agent that I had and
so I wanted to be the number one at the
agency and so we passed him and didn't
look back on YouTube then it became Gary
Vaynerchuk who's gonna be the first to
million and we passed him and now
there's not somebody to look up to and
say hey Who am I gonna compete with them
and go again so I'm hoping Gary passes
me and hoping grant gets back up there
I'm hoping Tom bill you explodes because
the come
tition is good because we're all
creating amazing things and I like that
little extra push to get me going
further so thinking about somebody in
your industry who can help give you that
little extra push it's not the reason
why are you doing it but it can give you
a little bit extra motivation to push
harder next rule number four is
collaborate what is the role of
collaboration toward those very early
days for you right with the batches the
amanda cerny x' of the world and now
today when you're rubbing shoulders with
Kevin Hart and the rock yeah um so if
you don't know who King batching Amanda
Cerny are their fellow internet creators
some of the biggest people on the
internet and when I first started I mean
even now still collaborations are huge
they hope they help you grow and cross
promote exchange audiences which is
always phenomenal but when I'm doing
collaborations with the rock and Kevin
Hart which I've been fortunate and lucky
enough to have done recently and our
collaborations have killed it to me the
role to answer your question is that it
elevates Who I am and what my brand is
because when you're doing videos like
I've always been doing but with a-list
celebrities not only does that make
people think of you or one in a
different way I also think as a whole
digital stars get a little bit more
respect oh now he's working with the
rock the Kevin Hart Justin Bieber and I
think it's it's good for everyone that
does what I do one of the fastest ways
to grow any business is to collaborate
and partner up whether that's in digital
we're making content having people on
your channel you go in their channel but
also in business the fastest way to grow
business is to find somebody who already
has your target audience your target
customers and find a way to be able to
work together and so it's great to Logan
applied this to his YouTube channel and
you've exploded that it took off and
continued well and you could do the same
thing for whatever your business is to
moving on rule number five is get the
word of mouth there's sharing that can
be done through social media when you
actually hit a share or retweet but
there's also which i think is a little
more familiar to this world the word of
mouth effect and I have gotten to
achieve that as well so the kids go to
school
and they talk about what happened in the
vlog the day before versus just sharing
a funny video it's like it's become a
Passat ik these kids I watch me 15
minutes a day they're a part of my life
and so they want to tell their friends
about it and when I do the crazy things
like filling up first-class bathroom
with my clothing line the kids go to
school they talk about and then it gets
occasionally typical mainstream media
presses word-of-mouth word-of-mouth
yes marketing of a best marketing ever
anyhow it's crazy is until about six
months ago I didn't realize that because
I'm a social media guy and then when it
became like oh snap this is like people
are talking in real life about this
that's when I think the celebrity effect
sort of happens every business can get
word-of-mouth and it's so important for
your company because you don't have the
budget to go off and buy Super Bowl
commercials and have a huge advertising
spend to promote what you're doing so
creating something where people want to
talk about you whether that's inherent
in your product or service whether
that's in the content you're creating
whether that's the story of to why you
started your business or the values that
you have and this crazy idea that you're
doing it doesn't have to be some big
radical bold thing but something that
brings enough value so that if I am
consuming whatever it is you have it
makes me feel good to share it with
somebody else you need to get
word-of-mouth marketing as an
entrepreneur let's get going to rule
number six
be creative what advice would you give
to people out there who really want to
become you like they want to get into
social media
everyone's I mean there's so many things
now between you two between all the
different around what was your advice to
okay do it and to actually be successful
okay first off you got to be different
you got to be creative and you got to
fill fill your niche right so like I was
the crazy college kid who wasn't like
afraid to be weird in front of people or
like make myself or maybe sometimes
other people uncomfortable I think you
also know I have to know how to light
and
shoot angles everything that's all
important like the aesthetic of what
you're shooting what it looks like and
then also post-production editing very
important so it's like a combination of
a few things you can get by if you don't
but it's like it can't be formulized
like if you got those three things you
should be social media famous I think
the key for me from this is figuring out
do you want to be a copycat of somebody
else who do you want to be your own
version and so if you're just copying
somebody else if you want to be the next
Logan Paul the best thing you can do is
model everything from him and then be
Logan Paul jr. but what you want to do
is learn from him and learn from other
people to find the creative thing inside
you that allows you to be different you
want to have ultimate success trying to
be the next Logan Paul or being the next
Evan Carmichael it's pulling those
pieces from different people
experimenting finding your own inner
creativity and allowing that come out so
that you are the first you that's where
you get your success I think this next
reel ties in really well rule number
seven
find your passion where did you get your
inspiration for creating new videos I
don't know like when I was like I said
ten I asked my dad for a video camera
and I don't know why like I don't know
where that came from I grew up in the
middle of the woods in Ohio and
something about the aesthetic of putting
things on a screen was like exhilarating
to me I was shooting still photography
of flowers for two years before I even
picked up a video camera because we
couldn't afford a video camera but I
could afford a digital camera and I
don't know something about creating
lucky for me to this day I still love it
it's a great quick message again big
decisions with the heart small ones with
the head if you follow a thing you
follow your heart follow what your
passion about it may not make sense
immediately but if you keep doing that
consistently I promise you it's gonna
pay off
up next rule number eight surround
yourself with the right people another
key to success is I surround myself with
the right people literally I have the
best team we have we have a model of
killers only so people who are the best
in their field because I'm smart enough
to realize that I'm not the best
videographer so I got the best
videographer I got the best manager I
got the best PR people I got the best
editor and together it just creates this
brand this biz
this that has today become a household
name another super important message
just remember that you may not be able
to start with that and that's okay
don't look at Logan Paul and say well
he's the only successful because he has
these world-class people around him it's
not how he started it's figuring out
what you have Michael Jordan level
talent at and then trying to spend as
much time doing that as possible and
have a vision to be able to expand your
business to bring on these people so at
the beginning you don't have spending
tons of money and you're not off trying
to recruit the best team because you may
not be able to afford them and you're
not quite good enough to get at what
you're doing yet either but as you start
the build and get traction it has to be
your intention to let go of the things
that you do not have Michael Jordan
level talent at or want to develop so
that you can bring on those world-class
people to help the system moving on rule
number nine be devoted to your craft I
devote serious time to this just as I
would so like in high school it was
sports now it's it's it's this video
stuff and I love it and how does it work
with college yeah that's that's it's
hard integrate both or vine like in the
colleges because the studying and stuff
but like I said without sports I still
have free time yeah and so you know most
kids they'll go out i'ma go vine being
devoted to your craft and working really
really hard is something that every
successful person has in common you need
to focus you need to dedicate you need
to spend time on the thing that will
help you get better the quantity leads
to the quality and Logan's talking in
this clip about having a hard time
balancing school eventually he dropped
out of college so that he could focus on
this full-time and his career took off
you know when you focus when you find
the thing that that's your opportunity
you have a limited amount of time to
make that happen your window is going to
close I need to jump through it with all
your effort all your might all your
focus to make sure that it happens let's
finish this awesome video up with rule
number 10 have fun my name is Logan Paul
in honor of the 2016 Olympics I'm gonna
split the world
come
[Music]
that was an awesome clip I need to work
on my splits I am nowhere close to be
able to do something like that but an
interesting challenge
so thank you guys so much for watching I
love to know what rule had the biggest
impact on you and why what are you going
to immediately apply somehow into your
life or your business leave it down the
comments below
I'm excited to hear what you have to say
I think my favorite rule is number four
which is collaborate I've done a lot of
collaborations mostly with other
youtubers and with some celebrities
within the business space I'm intrigued
by the day of doing something on a
bigger scale and what that might look
like so it's gonna get me thinking and
stay tuned for what might come but again
I'd love to know what was your favorite
rule of why leaving the comments below
now I made this video because bunny key
bad mushiya asks you to if there's a
famous entrepreneur that you would like
me to cover next check out the link in
description to the request line video
where you can leave a comment and vote
for your favorite entrepreneur I also
want to give a quick charter to Noah
Sachs Noah thank you so much for picking
up a copy of my book your one word and
doing the Instagram post on it I really
appreciate the support man and I'm so
glad you enjoyed my book so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever you're one where
it is much love I'll see you soon
what I do love is if I can partner with
a brand who has the same goals and
values and and brand awareness as me
that's like when it becomes truly
organic because every brand I'll have
ever done has literally been the best
ever like that they've ever done I am
the best in the world at integrating
brands into content and social media
there's no one better than I am and
that's because I carefully choose who
I'm gonna do it with and how I'm gonna
do with Hannes was one of the first big
brand deals that I did that was like
okay like I have enough money to move to
Los Angeles and they let me do my thing
that gave me creative control granted we
went back and forth but it's become just
this it's it's a flawless integration
into my life but what what are you
saying I think is that you and your
values have to be on the same page
as the brand in its values absolutely
has to otherwise otherwise I'm a sellout
otherwise I'm just doing social media
for money and I've never done that I
think that's also important I've never
I've never created content for money
like I love making videos and if a brand
can also increase or heighten the logan
paul brand the Maverick brand and make a
video that's shareable that helps me as
well it's not it's not just about the
money so is you you mentioned all these
different platforms it's not the same
content you're putting on each platform
right walk us through just briefly like
how do you program Facebook versus
Twitter versus Instagram yeah the uses
of these platforms so it's a little
easier now because Facebook Instagram
Twitter they all allow you to do at
least 60 second videos but I'll tailor
content for each platform so YouTube if
I have a sketch that's a min a minute
and a half like one of my most famous
sketches is with my door friend his name
is dwarf mom but it's called best
friends yeah that went insanely insane
what's the number on it 250 million of
Facebook Wow which is like I don't know
what the most video most viewed video on
Facebook is but like I I would bet that
its top five top ten yeah yeah yeah no I
know no video has hit a billion and for
a while that I thought that could do it
and but yeah on YouTube it's a minute
and a half on Facebook I tailored it
down to
a minute in like five just cuz you can
have the freedom on YouTube to do the
little bit of longer content but
Facebook there's sort of a formula and
arc and Instagram as well you want to
take people on this rollercoaster ride
but they get bored really fast vine the
platform I started out on six second
videos like kids attention spans
nowadays we're just shortening and
shorting it sucks but like it's the
world we live in so you have to get it
the punch quick as you can see Hawaii as
always looking beautiful the Sun is
setting right there
not gonna lie I took some fire pictures
myself my dad Logan Paul if you want to
follow me there I don't know what it is
about like views like this maybe it's
maybe it's cuz I'm around my friends I'm
just a really just happy relaxed place
right now what you guys noticed about me
I work really really hard but yeah I
know I don't want to say that I I do but
I enjoy it that's the thing for me
luckily I have found what I love to do
like genuinely love to do and I get to
do it every day and the fact that you
guys like it literally means the world
to me
as always to keep pushing to find what
it is that you love so every day you can
wake up knowing you want to work hard
but you don't have to work raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
value is that we believe that people
need passion and not one drop of myself
work depends on Europe it's suppose to
mean I don't ever give up
I'd have to be dead or completely
incapacitated hey believe nation if you
want to see my all-time favorite top ten
roses success I have a very special
secret video for you these are the
individual clips that I have personally
learned the most from and applied to my
life and my business check the link the
description for details